All right. Let's go through it together--for optional arguments,
there are two possibilities.
The arguments could be: at least one--some real arguments--
or they could be Empty.
The first two lines are going to look a bit like this.
We have to call our nonterminal (optargs)
because that's what I called it up here, and it has to match.
I'm just going to make up this new nonterminal, (args),
meaning "one or more".
If we don't see any of them, we can return the Empty list.
This means there's one or more arguments
so I'll just pass the buck and assume that (args) is magically
going to make, for me, the answer I want.
And I'll just copy it from p[1] into p[0].
One of the real tricky parts of handling arguments
is that they're separated by commas,
rather than terminated by commas.
So once you have your first argument--
if you're going to have a second, you need a comma but otherwise, you don't.
This seems a little weird when we say it verbally,
but if you look at it, it's more or less just what we expect.
If there's only one argument,
then it's just an expression--some number.
But if there are more, then we put commas in between them.
So here, for multiple arguments, we have an expression,
a comma, and then any more arguments we like.
And then, finally, we get to the last one,
which is just an expression.
For this one, we'll just make a Singleton list
out of the only argument you gave me.
So this would be the list, containing (1), for this example up here.
And in this other case--myfun(2,3)--
we take this first part--just the (2)--
and we put it in a list by itself,
and then we use (+) to get list concatenation--
list.append--to put this single element list
together with all of the rest of the arguments we've gathered up.
That's it for defining parsing functions
for function calls and arguments.